david bowie comme annoncé donc est notre
invité ce soir pour son dernier album
intitulé earth ling en français
traduction littérale le terrien en
parlant des titres de cet album la star
explique elle confirmera peut-être dans
quelques instants qu'elle n'a rien fait
de mieux musicalement parlant
depuis dix ans oui car lorsqu il fête
ses 50 ans david bowie ne veut manquer
de rien surtout pas d'humour comme son
nouveau disque au titre évidence le
terrien
- 2
ça
au moins nous
depuis 30 ans c'est sa manière de en
effet nos études box différentes pour
l'inévitable concert anniversaire à new
york il ya un mois david bowie préfère
d'abord surprendre ses amis musiciens
invités pour la fête en piégeant les
partitions et arrivée du même coup à
fleurir le très sérieux lou reed
david a tout changé les accords la
mélodie des fous j'ai même durée après
mes propres chances le pire c'est que
c'était pas mal les sacs répétition
c'était le soudan dans la communauté les
biens son sport préféré
pour télé live premier extrait de son
nouvel album mais surtout la première
chanson lancée sur internet
avec un 21e album détonnant david bowie
montre une fois encore son talent de
caméléon capable depuis trois décennies
de s'adapter à son époque
c'est peut-être même le contraire
david bowie bonsoir carrément soir
j'avais intitulé votre disent que votre
cd terriens en français pourquoi faire
du mais elle c'est à dire vous êtes
revenu sur terre dans votre musique est
tout à fait pas la wii s'est très
thématiques alors je disais tout à
l'heure que vous dites vous même de
votre de votre cd que c'est ce que vous
avez fait mieux depuis très très
longtemps dire quoi vous aviez laissé un
peu la musique de côté tels que vous
l'aimiez non sûr que c'est ce que j'ai
fait de mieux depuis un an c'est pas
très longtemps
non donc j'ai beaucoup aimé ce que j'ai
fait dans les années 90 je suis très
amicale avec mon oeuvre nous sommes très
proches et on dit par exemple qu'il ya
des titres des années 80 comme les
danses que vous ne voulait plus entendre
parler aujourd'hui pourtant ça a été un
succès mondial
je crois que c'était vraiment l'époque
beaucoup plus que la musique me sentais
pas à l'aise dans les années 80 je
ressentais une différence surtout vers
le milieu des années 80 à mesure qu'on
avançait vers les années 90 je me sentis
rafraîchi j'aimais bien écrire la
musique beaucoup plus sur ce cd vous
êtes habillé avec un drapeau anglais il
tout à fait pourquoi bien l'idée au
départ était de récupérer une partie de
l'ironie de la scène de l'art pop des
années 60 c'était une grande tendance à
l'époque de porter le drapeau du monde
différentes formes donc c'était un petit
peu un regard sur cette période
avec également un côté du xviiie siècle
côté coloniale c'est en fait la
rétrospective de l'angleterre telle
qu'on souhaiterait le garder présent à
l'esprit est ce que par exemple vous
regrettez que hong kong retourne à la
chine posez la question à moi non non
j'ai pas vraiment d'idée là dessus
j'y suis allé lorsque c'était sous les
angles et j'y retournerais sous les
chinois pendant que les chinois sortent
du kit de tibère vous avez l'habitude
d'alterner les albums pour le grand
public et les albums pour pour vos fans
pour ceux qui vous aiment celui ci c'est
un album destiné au grand public
oui je crois que c'est pour moi et
pendant gros que ça a été écrit de
manière assez égoïste on a écrit
expressément pour s'amuser et je pense
que certains quelque part les mots alors
vous êtes chanteur vous êtes homme
d'affaires vous êtes artiste homme
d'affaires vous venez de lancer un
emprunt de 50 millions de dollars sur
votre oeuvre à venir
pourquoi oui pareil je dois vous dire
que l'argent il comptait beaucoup mais
c'est pour pouvoir profiter de cet
argent tout de suite c'est pour pourquoi
pourquoi sa femme bros sur bien sûr tout
à que vous tapez vous n'êtes pas dans
les ennuis vous n'avez pas d'ennuis
financiers
non non j'en ai plus la plus maintenant
et pourquoi alors qu'est ce qu'est ce
qui vous a pris d'avoir cette idée je
crois que c'est une idée très novatrice
et je m'attends à ce que les rock stars
face la cupra la même chose alors dans
quelques semaines vous allez donc la
dent d'un film qui s'appelle basquiat
c'est l'histoire d'un jeune peintre
français qui a vécu aux états unis dans
ce film vous jouez le rôle d'andy warhol
qui était son mécène son ami qui a été
aussi un de vos amis
vous avez aimé jouer dans ce film
oui j'aime beaucoup de processus plupart
des gens qui étaient dans le film des
amis porte heureusement donc c'était
très informel très détendu approche
style ateliers le réalisateur est un
peintre américain craig lynch naba
c'était donc son premier film si bien
que la façon que nous avons travaillé
étaient beaucoup plus informelle que la
plupart des films encore une question
vient de voir andy warhol ce sont les
années 70 est-ce que vous david bowie
vous sentez un peu survivant d'une
époque où on a vous avez abusé de tous
oui je le crois et j'en suis sorti sans
trop de problèmes bien vous pouvez
reprendre votre position normale merci
david bowie et bonne chance pour ce vrai
cd que vous seriez vraiment merci
beaucoup merci nous avoir rendu visite